porque tanta confusión en alemania que
han finalmente será el sucesor de merkel
y porque el cd&v asegura que ellos
pueden formar entonces también un
gobierno cuando el spd lleva al
adelantar y precisamente tenemos
imágenes en vivo que nos llegan a desde
alemania está hablando pues la cdu vamos
a ver qué pasa es raúl pero por favor
saquen os de la duda
bueno el resultado ha sido muy ajustado
es obvio que el que les pedía gana las
elecciones con un punto coma 6 de
diferencia frente a la cdu que ha tenido
el peor resultado de su historia y olaf
scholz ha dicho que tiene un mandato
claro de los alemanes para formar
gobierno ayer en la tradicional ronda de
los elefantes que se celebra justo al
conocer los primeros resultados con los
candidatos de todos los partidos armin
lancet quiero' quiso defender también su
derecho a formar una coalición en este
caso con los liberales y con los verdes
pero yo creo que las primeras
negociaciones se van a dar entre olaf
scholz les pide y los liberales y los
verdes que ayer empezaron a animar un
poco esperezas entre ellos porque son
claramente los dos partidos que más
fuerza tiene harán que sean más pequeños
porque son los que estarán sí o sí en el
próximo gobierno y son ellos los que
elegirán quién les acompañan como
canciller pero tienen que ponerse de
acuerdo en muchas cosas en las que ahora
mismo tienen posiciones antagónicas
ahora raúl como podría estar conformada
esta nueva coalición de gobierno en
alemania que se puede esperar
bueno se pueden esperar muchas semanas
incluso meses de negociaciones
recordemos que en el año 2017 en las
últimas elecciones el gobierno no se
formó hasta marzo de 2018 tardaron seis
meses porque se rompieron las
negociaciones para entonces también una
coalición jamaica y acabó habiendo un
gobierno de coalición entre la cdu y el
spd y yo creo que aquí lo básico es que
esta coalición es la coalición de los
tres partidos que han aumentado votos
son los tres partidos únicos que han
subido votos con respecto al 2017 son
tres partidos digamos de centro aunque
es verdad que los liberales están más en
el aspecto de la derecha que tienen
diferencias por ejemplo en el tema de
impuestos los liberales quieren no subir
impuestos los verdes y los y los
socialdemócratas quieren subir los
impuestos a las personas con más
recursos y tienen también diferencias en
temas de salario mínimo y otras y otros
temas yo creo que ahí la clave está en
que los liberales que se quedaron fuera
en 2017 y se arrepienten muchísimo de
aquella decisión den un paso al frente y
le puedan otorgar a esa coalición
digamos de centroizquierda entre espere
y los verdes un complemento también
moderado de centroderecha que situaría a
ese nuevo gobierno en el centro político
alemán y que podría satisfacer muchas
demandas de diferentes segmentos de la
población raúl habladas hablas del
partido verde y también le quiero
preguntar entonces cómo que cómo llega a
este partido verde a estas elecciones y
también qué hay de la extrema derecha
que lectura se le puede hacer luego a
estos comicios
el partido verde ayer la candidata hasta
la vía muy triste en el debate entre los
entre los diferentes candidatos a pesar
de haber sacado el mejor resultado de la
historia y haber sido el partido que más
ha crecido con respecto a 2017 pero
claro las expectativas eran otras
recordemos que los verdes llegaron a
liderar las encuestas allá por abril y
mayo con el 26 o el 27 por ciento de los
votos y que a partir de ahí por errores
de la candidata y por una campaña sucia
que ya que ya sufrió pues empezó a
perder apoyos así que estaban tristes
pero en realidad van a tener más fuerza
que nunca van a estar seguros seguro en
el gobierno e internamente se va a
reposicionar un poco el partido porque
hasta ahora y ya la en la verbo que era
la líder y candidata pero comparte el
liderazgo con roberts javier y él creo
que va a tomar posiciones también a la
hora d liderar las negociaciones y en el
caso de la ultraderecha ha perdido
apoyos pero sigue manteniendo un 10% y
ha quedado como primera fuerza en dos
regiones del este en sax en y touring ya
es decir la ultraderecha ha ganado en
dos regiones de alemania en las
elecciones al bundestag es segunda
fuerza en los territorios del este
alemán ya en la antigua rda la alemania
comunista y sigue teniendo mucha
presencia en la política alemana porque
ha bajado porque su tema prioritario del
que solo les gusta hablar para entrar en
el debate de la inmigración no ha sido
un tema de campaña raúl rápidamente
tenemos 40 segundos como deja merkel a
alemania y qué retos le espera el
principal reto pues por el tiempo que
tenemos la espera al que la suceda bueno
el reto la desigualdad de alemania es un
país muy desigual a pesar de eso la
primera locomotora europea el reto de la
digitalización y también el de la lucha
contra el cambio climático no son
menores los retos que le espera el
próximo gobierno